star wars battlefront reminds me why I
love Star Wars its skirmishes unfold
across iconic planets with gorgeous
landscapes and sweeping vistas on a
massive scale endures trees dwarf us
tattooing desert stretches for miles and
when the battle music reaches its peak
and I glide over hops frozen trenches I
remember the first time I watched that
scene unfold but Star Wars Battlefront
lacks the longevity that makes its
source material great
it offers initial engagement and for the
first 10 hours it swept me through its
harrowing firefights at a rapid pace
but then the cracks began to show in the
end battlefront feels more like an
homage to Star Wars than a substantial
Star Wars game in itself so if nothing
else Star Wars Battlefront is an
exercise in pure spectacle laid out in
all of its neon glory I still can't help
but smile when Boba Fett's slave one
guns down three fighters in a row or a
snow speeder careens past with flames
trailing in its wake the first 10 hours
are packed with these moments and it's
worth playing just to watch them unfold
I will crush this rebellion